in our inflationary World filled with
Fiat currencies and money printing
increasing prices is simply a reality of
daily life whether you're trying to buy
a house a cup of coffee or a nice meal
you can bet the prices are only going to
go up over the long term in the 1960s
for example a Big Mac only cost 45 today
a Big Mac costs over 10 times that at
$495 this trend is especially true in
the world of new tech where companies
are constantly trying to create the next
big thing and charge as much as possible
however in this universe of inflation
there is one notable exception TVs even
if you don't follow TV prices too
closely you've probably noticed TV
prices creeping down whenever you sto bu
them at Costco or Best Buy nowadays you
can get 4k TVs for as little as $200 and
85in 4K TVs for just $800 or less than
the price of a flagship smartphone just
10 years ago both of these would have
costed you thousands of dollars but is
this just a case of new TV tech becoming
cheaper or are TV prices actually
falling across the board well if you
take a look at the historical price of
TVs it becomes clear that it's very much
the latter basically since 1950 TVs have
been consistently falling in price there
have been a few years here and there
where they went up but most of those
years had inflation that was even higher
so the real prices of TVs were still
going down this trend has only
accelerated over the past 20 years
during which TVs have been consistently
Falling by at least 15% every single
year at the same time TVs have been
consistently getting bigger and better
as well at the turn of the century the
average TV was only 24 in today the
average TV is 50 in we've also gone from
plasma TVs to LCDs to LEDs to oleds Q
LEDs Neo Q LEDs mini LED and who knows
what else not to mention resolutions
seemed to be endlessly going up as well
so somehow we're able to get bigger and
better TVs than ever for a lot cheaper
than ever so here's the inexplicable
economics of TVs and how TV prices keep
falling into a seemingly endless
Abyss taking a look back the phenomenon
of TVs falling in prices can be traced
all the way back to the beginning of TVs
themselves well technically the
technology used in TVs can actually be
traced back to the early 1800s but we're
more focused on Modern commercial TVs
which takes us back to September of
1928 this is when the first commercially
produced television set was shown off to
the public this however was terrible
timing as the Great Depression hit just
one year later making it extremely
difficult to introduce new consumer Tech
into the market in fact fact it would
take a full 10 years for this
demonstration to turn into a widely
available product but it was very much
worth the way to given that it would
become an instant success but all of
this was just the beginning it wasn't
until after World War II and after
America entered a new age of prosperity
and economic growth that people really
started splurging on homes cars and of
course TVs but not only were TV sales
going to the moon so was TV tech
starting in 1946 we would see a heated
race between CBS and RCA to bring color
TVs into every household CBS would end
up beating RCA to Market but not without
making a massive sacrifice the color
television sets that CBS came up with
weren't compatible with the black and
white TV sets that millions of Americans
already had nonetheless the FCC would
declare CBS color TVs as being the new
National Standard instead of fighting
against the FCC on this decision though
RCA would simply continue developing a
more compatible color TV stand standard
and the FCC would eventually concede
that RCA's design was much more
practical making them the new standard
in 1953 it was a classic case of
American capitalism working and the
better invention coming out on top but
honestly none of this really mattered it
wasn't until 13 years later in 1966 when
color TV broadcasting became more
popular that people actually started
buying color TVs and this brings us into
the first unique factor of the TV Market
which is that it has always had a
massive adoption delay the first color
tv started popping up in the late 40s
and early 50s but they didn't really
gain steam till the late' 60s and it's
the same case to this day OLED for
example was created in the late 1980s
and it first started showing up in TVs
in 2004 but it's only now that the
general public is buying into OLED and
even now there's still a lot of room for
growth for whatever reason people are
willing to be extremely patient with TVs
which is in stark contrast to any other
tech industry take smartphones for
example 5G didn't even start getting
deployed till 2018 and 2019 and it was
until the 2020s that it was actually
widely available yet by the end of 2022
itself over a 100 million Americans or
about a third of the country already had
5G with most Tech Industries people want
the absolute latest and greatest they're
often reluctant to buy something even
two or three generations old but it's
the the complete opposite with TVs with
TVs people are not only willing to buy 5
to 7-year-old Tech but they're also
happy to dis on new tech just 10 years
ago it was extremely popular to HTE on
4K the common belief seemed to be that
you couldn't even tell a difference
between 1080P and 4K and that 4K was a
waste of money that was until 4K became
dirt cheap and people completely forgot
about their concerns and picked up a 4K
TV the same thing is happening with 8K
as we speak who even needs 8 K you can't
even tell the difference 8K is so stupid
there's not even 8K content and on and
on and on it's actually crazy how heated
people get over a new TV tech the
reality is that if you have an 85 or 98
in TV which are increasingly becoming
the norm you can tell a difference
between 4K and 8K just not a difference
that's worth an extra $3 to
$4,000 if you give it 5 to 10 years
though and wait for 8K TV prices to
become comparable to 4K TV prices you
can bet that the general public will
forget all about their concerns and buy
an 8K TV and honestly that's great
people are happy to buy the new TV tech
when it's offered at a reasonable price
but until then they're somehow
completely immune to marketing hype if
consumers approached every industry with
this mindset credit card debt wouldn't
even be a thing but unfortunately this
magical consumer Clarity only applies to
the TV industry which brings us into the
question of
why
trying to answer why consumers aren't
moved by TV marketing is a rather tough
question to answer the obvious
explanation is that TVs are a matured
Market that isn't progressing all that
quickly so it's easy for consumers to
settle on something that's a bit older
but that's not really true there's quite
a big difference between regular LED TVs
and OLED TVs
definitely a much bigger difference than
the iPhone 12 versus the iPhone 15 yet I
feel that it would be much easier to
convince someone to hold back and buy an
LED TV than it would be to get them to
buy an iPhone 12 and it's not just with
smartphones either I could make the same
argument with cars assuming that all
prices were the same it would be much
harder to convince someone to buy a
10-year-old car than buy an LED TV and
cars don't even change and this brings
me into one of the most basic Basic
Marketing roles features don't sell
products automakers and apple understand
this perfectly TV makers do not for
decades TV makers have been trying to
push TVs based on new tech whether that
be OLED or 8K or whatever consumers
aren't really moved by features though
they're moved by Apparent change for
example unless you're a TV nerd you
probably don't even know the difference
between OLED qled Neo qled and mini LED
but regardless of how knowledgeable you
are on TVs I bet you remember when TVs
went from being boxes to being flat or
when they went from being 24 in to being
85 in these sort of changes may not
actually make that big of a difference
to picture quality compared to LED
versus OLED in fact bigger TVs usually
have worse picture quality but
nonetheless there are often much more
compelling reasons to upgrade if
everyone around you has upgraded from
box TVs to flat screen TVs or from 55 in
TVs to 85 in TVs you'd probably want to
upgrade as well this is precisely the
formula that automakers leverage every
couple of years automakers will change
up the design of their cars just to keep
things feeling fresh and new this way by
the time your current car is 10 to 15
years old even if everything's working
perfectly fine it feels old and outdated
it's the same case with the apple with
every generation they try to add
something that makes it distinctly clear
that it's the new one for example
iPhones that still have home buttons
definitely feel outdated iPhones with
The Notches as opposed to Dynamic
islands are even starting to feel
outdated despite it being a non-material
difference honestly at this point
there's not much more that can change
with the iPhone's design and that's why
apple is dragging those out for as long
as possible things like removing the
dynamic island or camera bump alt
together with TVs on the other hand
they've basically always been in their
final form it's only a few times in
history that the the design has
fundamentally changed at which points
people did upgrade quickly but putting
those instances aside there's really no
obvious difference between any of the
new TV standards sure they are better
and you do want it but unless you put
them side by side you often wouldn't
even notice a difference so people are
able to be surprisingly patient when it
comes to new TV tech and they don't
particularly feel left behind or left
out either leading to astounding
consumer Clarity but while this is great
for consumers it sucks for TV makers
leading to some pretty odd
Solutions given this consumer sentiment
TV makers have been trying to introduce
material changes as regularly as
possible but most of these efforts end
up falling flat for example remember
that time that TVs went from being flat
to being curved to being flat again or
what about that time that 3D TVs were
supposedly the next big thing the
reality is that it's extremely difficult
to force changes like these unless
you're apple and over the years TV
makers have come to accept this reality
instead they've turned their attention
to alternative mode demonetization like
data collection it turns out that your
viewing habits are extremely valuable to
streaming services like Netflix and
Disney plus so TV makers no longer even
need to make money when you buy the TV
instead they make their money in the
following 5 to 10 years selling your
data to streaming Giants in fact the
average margin across the TV industry is
only 6% and that's with the stupid
expensive 8K o80 TVs pulling that margin
up so if you buy a regular TV with a
strong discount on Black Friday or
Christmas there's a good chance that you
got that TV at cost or even under cost
at this point larger Brands like LG and
Samsung don't even care all that much
about postp purchase monetization either
for them the TV industry has become
something that they use to Simply
maximize brand presence and dominance as
opposed to really making money so why
did TV prices keep going down well
you've of course got all of your classic
stuff like economies of scale the
commoditization of TVs and new tech
making old Tech cheaper and all that
jazz but the real bottom line is that
the general public simply does not buy
into TV marketing hype so after TV
makers burn through the rich buyer who
can afford to burn a couple Grand
they're forced to quickly decrease
prices to appeal to a much broader
audience some TV makers have figured out
alternative modes of monetization but
for the most part TVs have become a near
zero margin industry that companies just
use to stay relevant and omnipresent
resulting in TV prices falling forever
Samsung is starting to feel the same
squeeze within the smartphone industry
as we enter the era of peak smartphone
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Sor and I'll see you guys
on the next
one